my name is Michael Deacon I'm vice
president of technology investment
company km core we invest in information
technologies and were looking for
potential investments in in Africa so
I'm addressing the question about the
the highest standards of corporate
governments and the commitment from
business community to uphold these tents
I think this is a question to leadership
is a most important thing that leaders
of the countries have a tougher stance
on the corporate governments and
internal governments that they have in
their countries so if a strong leader
believes that that he knows or she knows
was in a interests of the country so all
this investors and all this businessman
who are already in this country so I
wanted to enter can be can be persuaded
to uphold the standards and from a
position of the government so if the
government has a clear way knowledge of
where it's going and can have em has a
strong leader Sheikh he can or it can
uphold the standards to the business
community thank you